[Music]
darkness is the Cannabis of the light is
my brush with life painting you can
create new worlds into darkness my name
is Hana booth Domo and I paint with
light
I live in Finland we have amazing nature
here we have a long summer nights that
are warm and full of light but on the
opposite there is also this dark part
it's called polar night
it starts in December and it lasts for
about 50 days the Sun doesn't rise above
the horizon at all and for a light
painter that is quite good I do long
exposure photography which is a
photographic technique that allows me to
draw with light the exposure times can
vary from a seconds to hours and the
idea is to use the light sources as
approaches or pencils and the dark
surroundings are the cannabis when I
start I might do some sketches on paper
after that I go to the location I search
for details that I want to emphasize
with some light treatment it will start
to look like a completely a new place
going to dark woods or to abandoned
house you first think that oh I don't
want to go there because there's just so
nasty looking dark places but too light
painting I have examined these places
and they look beautiful you see the
place differently
you
[Music]